[Music]
by having an actual prosecutor a
competent strong prosecutor
and her team that has been just put
together days ago of strong known tried
and tested prosecutors is going to make
a very fundamental change you could even
say that san francisco is undergoing an
earthquake per se in the criminal
justice system
[Music]
mayor london breed has chosen brooke
jenkins a an experienced prosecutor one
who has been in the district attorney's
office for approximately seven years
uh even before vodin took office
she was an excellent choice i was i was
very happy i was ecstatic uh and i know
that she's going to do a great job
she has the backing of many important
people and in fact in the last few days
she has put together a preliminary uh
leadership team of of all women people
that are also very well
very well respected we all look forward
to
now cleaning this up
that this is what brent jenkins is
talking about we're dealing with the the
drug dealers that lead to this kind of
pockets of drug dens that are scattered
around san francisco
and and we all have our fingers crossed
it it we we all have hope now that uh
brooke jenkins is going to come through
with her promise
to uh to deal with the the drug dealers
and to help
eradicate
this kind of uh scenes that we reap that
are repeated over and over again
throughout parts of the city that have
gone unabated uh that have been caused
by gascon and former dhs verdin
yeah there's going to be a fundamental
change we're undergoing an earthquake
here in the criminal justice system
there's going to be a period of time now
under the new d.a brook jenkins to have
to rebuild confidence in the
prosecutor's office
with the voters with san franciscans
with business leaders here with business
owners and also the tourists because
we've all been
greatly affected by by having these
criminals running rampant on the streets
here with almost
no no
impunity